and i got the blues and my shoes and i
got a blue blow switch too so yeah
ariana grande's impression of celine
dion is so good truly i hope you're
ready for it me i was born ready just in
case there was any doubt about ari being
celine's biggest fan during monday
night's episode of the voice she proved
it yet again while in rehearsals with
contestants jim and sasha allen ariana
is an incredible coach and she's also an
incredible friend we feel so comfortable
with her she's the funniest person and i
got the blues and my shoes and i got a
blue blow switch too so yeah
sorry i i've spent a little too much
time watching her four-hour documentary
celine through the eyes of the world
i know everywhere but can we run that
impression back one more time oh my god
the blues in my shoes and i got a blue
blue sweatshirt
yeah that's ari doing an impression of
celine doing an impression of elvis
presley in her 2010 documentary celine
through the eyes of the world
[Music]
anyway if you thought that would be the
only time ari brought up the my heart
will go on singer during monday night's
episode think again because with the
voice coach all roads lead to celine not
to mention celine dion again like you
know at the end of titanic when she's
like
[Music]
that's the vibe even that's pretty
important she's really relevant she's
super relevant always it's so special
why are you so good at everything every
week
and it turns out that was good advice
because the folksy father-son duo took
the stage for their top 13 performance
covering your song by elton john
and you can tell everybody
this is a song
and they totally wowed the coaches
i'm telling you last week was
unbelievable and you did it again
i i'm so moved by you both and i hope
america votes for you both but back to
ari it's the most fun i've ever had in
my whole life this isn't the first time
she's busted out her impressive selene
impersonation skills it was a real
surprise in fact it's not even the first
time the 28 year old singer has busted
out her impressive celine on the voice
here she is giving it her all last month
indiana hello that's my run
oh my god i love your impression of her
and back in 2015 during a stop by the
tonight show starring jimmy fallon we
saw ari selene skills on full display
singing the weekend's hit track can't
feel my face in celine's iconic voice
[Music]
i mean
that's impressive oh thank you the 3435
singer is clearly a big fan of the 53
year old singer and when the two
attended the same event back in 2016 e.t
asked if she'd ever do her impression
for the music legend everyone is asking
me what i'm gonna do when i see celine i
think it's so funny that everyone knows
how much i love her um no i'm just gonna
be like
hi
okay so ari might not want to do her
impression in front of celine but
thankfully she doesn't shy away from
sharing it on the voice oh my god the
blues in my shoes and i got a blue blue
sweatshirt
and one thing's for sure the new coach
is bringing the competition this season
something kelly clarkson john legend and
blake shelton opened up to et about
leading up to the season 21 premiere she
is hugely talented hugely successful and
has legions and legions of fans that
know how to use the internet and vote
coming in i was prepared i came with in
battle armor
i'm prepared to be turned down we always
come out like you know and like like
i'll go john goes whatever and blake's
usually laughs he gets the most screams
and and and well
and then he used to he used to do and
then all of a sudden he was like can
ariana go before me because they lose
their mind
it's embarrassing to follow her it
exposes
my lack of celebrity being new there's
so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing
[Music]
you